I want to talk about the definition and
the challenges of global sustainability
and this really should be seen as a
concluding sum up of the whole class
because that's really what i'm doing
here so the definition includes
protecting ecosystems preventing and
adapting to climate change reducing air
and water pollution ensuring that we get
healthy food and enough of it developing
land and handling waste to ensure that
we don't poison ourselves also
preventing human conflict because you
know no matter what else we do to
preserve the planet the technology of
mass destruction has advanced to such a
degree that everything we do could be
wiped out in a thermonuclear exchange
that should terrify us and and certainly
does then I'll talk about how this will
be financed the organizational and
management challenges and finally the
role of government and public policy and
stimulating this so we'll start with a
definition which is really something
we've been talking about through most of
the semesters now I focus a lot on local
issues because in the sense the
environment is something you perceive
and and experience as an individual at
the community level but all local issues
when you have enough people on the
planet can in essence become global
issues sustainability issues should be
thought of really as a continuum from
some that are almost purely local and
can in fact be contained to those that
have actually impact global systems so
and and the interaction of these should
not be underestimated I mean the whole
environmental issue starts with people
like Rachel Carson tracking DDT and how
it literally came to the entire global
ecosystem and very common are doing the
same thing looking at nuclear testing
that takes place in the Pacific showing
up in the milk supply in Wisconsin
because those chemicals you could
actually trace because they were so
unique
environment so that so we learned about
the interconnectedness of the
environment and commoner in his landmark
book the closing circle made the point
that he created these laws of ecology
and one of his was everything is
connected to everything else and in
terms of our planet that's true but
everything is not as connected as
everything else some things in fact are
more global or than others so we need to
be thinking about sustainability issues
in terms of those things that have
planet wide impact because those are
going to be the toughest problems to
solve like climate change because our
nation states are still the way we
govern ourselves and frankly they will
stay the way we govern ourselves until
the threats to our security come from
other planets and I don't know that
that's going to happen in my lifetime
maybe it'll happen in yours but for the
moment national sovereignty is going to
remain our goal is to manage human
impact on the planet's natural systems
we are biological creatures see even
even Kermit and so we need the planet in
order to survive and I thought by now
that we would be have we would have
transcended our need for the planet but
we haven't we don't live in other
planets the Columbia University of the
earth is who actually it's very
beginning operated something called the
biosphere 2 in Oracle Arizona that's
where the MPA environmental science and
policy spent its first year we didn't
live inside the dome that experiment had
been gone but in fact that experiment
didn't work we really don't know how to
live in a self-sustaining ecological
system we don't understand all the
variables and we didn't there someday we
may have the technology to create our
own resources you know those replicators
on the Star Trek rocket ships but we
don't know how to do that yet and so we
are
duck with this planet and we better make
sure that it survives as if it doesn't
we don't we need though to develop a
sufficient understanding of our earth
systems processes to manage them because
our impacts are now global and so great
that we have to as we produce the things
we need to live on we need to minimize
our impact on the planet and we need to
increase the technology of observation
but also of energy we need to focus on
preserving biodiversity treat waste and
we have to figure out how to detect
weapons of mass destruction
technologically so they can't be used we
are in need to make sure that there is
never a dirty bomb going off in Times
Square because the minute it does all
bets are off and we need the
organizational capacity to manage
sustainability on a global scale which
means everybody here needs to know
enough about organizational management
that wouldn't these good ideas are
developed you can help make them happen
in organizations so let's focus first on
ecosystems our knowledge of the
ecosystems that we need to support life
on this planet is very incomplete we're
destroying oceans forests and freshwater
habitats worldwide at a rapid rate if
you listen to my colleague Shaheed
nayeem or Don Melnick from the ecology
department here at Columbia you can you
will easily be terrified but what they
have to say so we need to increase our
understanding of the science of ecology
in order to decrease our negative impact
on those systems ecosystems are complex
interactive webs or networks and
preventing damage is difficult than some
damage is irreversible so we need to
learn more about it so that when we do
the things that we want to do that we
don't in a sense kill the goose that
lays the golden eggs climate change the
planets temperature is constantly
changing it's done so throughout history
we know this but as I said earlier with
nearly 7 billion people on the planet
and in this country of hundreds of
millions of automobiles the idea that it
has no impact on the atmosphere is
ludicrous and scientists have been
demonstrating this impact for a while
and it's so unambiguous that you know
it's not really worth discussing it but
what we don't know is we really don't
know the impact we don't know what's
going to happen and that's in fact where
some of our scientists have got into
trouble they make projections and
they're only projections and so we need
to be a little bit more modest than how
we do that but we know that this is
happening and the reason it matters is
that our settlement patterns where we
live where we have our forms where our
infrastructure has been developed is
trillions of dollars of investment in a
given planet and a given set of
temperature and so if that changes
radically then those investments are out
the window I mean this is a coastal city
new york city has over 600 miles of
coastline and salvage some of the
neighborhoods in New York are very close
to sea-level some of it was built on
landfill my home in Brooklyn was not but
two blocks away it was I and the part of
bklyn I'm from that's called flatlands
and that's not because it was
mountainous so you know Columbia
University's on morningside heights but
manhattanville were rebuilding our new
campus is very close to sea level and so
though in the World Trade Center when it
was built they had to build a bathtub
under it for drainage reasons and the
big retaining wall to keep the river out
so when you think about the adaptation
to climate change it's going to cost a
lot of money so we need to be thinking
about how to reduce that essentially to
protect our investment now what's
interesting is the reason why the global
climate issue has made it on the
political agenda finally enlarge
measures because of reinsurance and
insurance companies companies like Swiss
ray who have billions at risk if this
stuff happens
okay because they're they're the ones
who are ensuring these investments and
and they are been starting to think
about what does climate change due to
the risk profile of our portfolio and a
lot of it's not so good and then when
you think about you know changes in
weather patterns you have more
hurricanes and more flooding and more
people living in coastal cities so we're
going to see these kinds of natural
disasters as a regular occurrence in our
in our world at with more and more human
impacts and so we're going to have to
develop ways to provide emergency
response and reconstruction on a regular
basis I mean it's going to be like the
modern version of the fire department
climate change poses profound challenges
to our international political regime
because the problems are caused
everywhere and their impact is in the
future it is the classic example of the
over grazed common field as somebody
mentioned earlier today in the case of
climate change though the most severe
impacts may take place in the future and
far away from where we cause the impacts
and as a political matter those are the
toughest problems to solve so I would
not underestimate the problem and so
that's part of why I don't think the
problem is going to be solved by a
direct assault on climate it will get
solved by changing the energy use that
we have the low carbon green economy is
within our reach technologically we
could actually make this happen if we
decided to focus our attention on it
just as we decided to go to the moon in
10 years you could decide to accelerate
the process of moving to a fossil fuel
free economy and I think that I was
hoping that was going to happen under
the current administration I think
President Obama wanted to do it I think
he's running into a political problem
and trying to make that happen okay
let's turn to air and water pollution
our economy can be managed to minimize
impacts on air and water
I mean EPA itself in the 1970s and 80s
demonstrated that because there used to
be these curves which showed gross
domestic product going up pollution
going up at the same or greater levels
in the mid and late 1970s into the 1980s
we see GDP going this way and pollutants
going that way so the technology of
pollution control is there we can apply
it we can develop it and it is advancing
technologically urbanization increases
stresses to air and water resources but
is amenable to technological fixes we
can actually manage our air and water
resources and we have done that the air
and water in this city is far cleaner
than it was 40 years ago there is really
almost no comparison the Hudson River
the East River were toxic sewers in the
1960s and 70s really into the 1980s and
they're not anymore and while the air is
not as clean as it should be or could be
in New York it's cleaner than it was in
the early 1960s until we stop doing this
in apartments in Manhattan every large
apartment had a basement incinerator and
the garbage was burned we literally
burned our garbage all over Manhattan
and then the late late evening early
morning hours there was a little haze
over the city of New York and it wasn't
a pretty sight okay food I've talked
about food earlier this semester the
food industry is a huge multi
billion-dollar multinational business
most of the people on this planet are no
longer involved in the production of
food and the food supply system is
largely invisible to the average person
a group of students i work with last
year in the NPA and environmental
science and policy program did an
analysis as a workshop project of how
new york city gets its food and where it
comes through very interesting piece of
work and what we discovered is that it's
one of the places in New York where the
capitalist market works beautifully if a
local
a grocery store runs out of strawberries
there's 10 other places that want to
sell it any month of the year the issue
will be price the issue will be
convenience but you can get it and
that's part of the advantage of living
in a city like this but we need to think
about reducing the ecological impact of
some of the production of food some of
the industrial food suppliers
particularly the suppliers of meat do
all sorts of nasty things to the water
near the feed locks that these animals
live live on and so all of those food
producing technologies can be fixed food
production though has to use technology
to keep pace with population this was
actually what Malthus was worried about
in his classic equation that that the
normal pace of production of food would
eventually be outstripped by population
and what we have discovered in fact is
that through the application of
technology and industrial farming we in
fact have a surplus of food worldwide
our problem is basically the
distribution of it and its environmental
impact so industrial agriculture has to
be made less destructive energy
fertilizer and water has to be used more
efficiently and if it is and again
that's a management and technology issue
then we can feed the seven or even ten
billion people that it looks like the
planet will grow too then there's the
issue of developing land and handling
our waste human population is growing
and settlements are an increasingly
fragile and vulnerable areas if you talk
to the people of New Orleans they can
tell you what that's about so waste
streams have to be more carefully
managed to maintain human and
environmental health we have to make
sure that our waste is treated that it's
seen as a resource that we recycle that
we reduce it that we transform it
chemically so it doesn't stay toxic and
contaminate our land and groundwater
land use and settlement patterns can be
managed to reduce environmental impacts
so in America suburban sprawl was a very
destructive way to develop well now we
have large parts of inner cities that
are ripe for development and you're
starting to see some of the
redevelopment of those cities and so
that I think is what you're going to see
more densely settled areas with wastes
of better managed and with less impact
on the ecology of the planet but this
last point I made earlier emergency
response and post-disaster
reconstruction are going to have to
become routine because we're going to
have flooding and hurricanes and
earthquakes now more and more were there
people I mean it just make sense when I
was growing up in the 1960s the planet
only had three billion people today we
have more than twice that now it's not
going to grow much more than I mean
probably the population the planet will
peak at 10 billion but that's still
three times as many as were around when
I was growing up and they got us they of
living somewhere and and what it means
is the probability than being impacted
by natural disasters is greater so we
have to build a governance system that
accommodates that we have to build a way
to respond to emergencies and
reconstruct after those emergencies take
place and then there's the issue of
human conflict Wars target people but
also can target human systems the idea
in warfare is actually to damage an
enemy's capacity to make war so you know
and this is not a new thing Sherman's
march to during the Civil War they
burned everything in sight they it was
an ecological disaster for the Sabbath
so warfare itself poses environmental
threats and threats to sustainability
but modern weapons of mass destruction
are truly the heart of our problem
chemical warfare biological warfare a
nuclear war everything that you do to
manage the planet can be affected by
that and as i said earlier in the
semester john kennedy and his famous
american university speech after he
face down Khrushchev during the Cuban
Missile Crisis looked at nuclear nuclear
exchange for what it really is which
would have been an ecological
catastrophe for the planet and he and he
said you know we all live on the small
planet we all cherish our children were
all mortal and so our common humanity
has to win out over the use of weapons
of mass destruction so far it's holding
there's only been you know one you know
one war where nuclear weapons were used
it was used twice and it's never been
used again now that doesn't mean it
won't be used to get but it hasn't been
used again which tells you that we're
capable of controlling these things
doesn't mean we're going to but it means
we're capable of it and the long run
here is that we have to figure out a way
to put this genie back in the bottle all
progress made in other arenas of
sustainability could be undermined by a
war fought with weapons of mass
destruction so for that reason the issue
of global security dominates all other
issues and is the single most important
of all sustainability issues if you
don't deal with this issue that this
issue is not addressed it really doesn't
matter what else you do okay so let's
talk about money resources now spent on
management practices that are not
sustainable will shift over time to
those that are the private market is
already starting to do this the fact
that the green part of the US economy is
growing faster than the rest even during
the recession is an indicator of that
but we're also going to have to find the
capital for the transition to a green
economy the smart grid is not going to
be cheap the the electric vehicles that
we need during are going to need to be
we need to need to fund the
infrastructure some of this capital will
be raised by the private sector by
utilities
but I think we're also going to need to
see at some point our taxes go up to
amass the capital obviously it's not
going to happen in the next 24 months
with the with the folks that have just
been elected to control the House of
Representatives I think that more
efficient and renewable energy will
reduce the percentage of the gdp devoted
to energy and I actually think that
sustainability is a way to create a more
efficient and effective economic machine
because in the long run something that's
renewable will be cheaper than something
that you use and throw away and by
reducing the ecological impact of our
development we will reduce the cost of
the cleanup that will inevitably follow
you may not realize it but you're now
paying the cost of all the cleanup of
toxic wastes that were dumped in the 40s
50s and 60s it's part every time you buy
something you're paying for that clean
up because most of the cleanup costs are
in fact being borne by the private
sector so we need to figure out a way to
do that but our organizations and our
political system is focused on the short
run elections are every two or four
years corporations are managed to
quarterly and and even more frequent
metrics of productivity and profit and
so this creates organizational and
management challenges we need to develop
the capacity to analyze these impacts we
need to know when we're doing things we
need to take these new technologies and
apply them and we need to know how to do
that that takes skill we need to
understand how to be change agents and
organizations and how to rapidly change
the standard operating procedures it's
not enough to have a new technology
available we need to know how to use it
and very often when a new technology
comes in it breaks down you know buy
yourself a new ipod when they just come
out you know it you never want to be the
early adopter right because you know
you're going to be bringing it back to
the store we need leadership by people
trained in the field of sustainability
management surprise surprise
most organizational leaders are either
lawyers or MBAs okay the people that run
organizations the people running
columbia university or lawyers a couple
of MBAs even have a couple of PhDs in
there but typically speaking the people
that run organizations have those
backgrounds they have no training in the
physical dimension of sustainability
they don't know the science of
environmental impacts or the engineering
of resource or energy efficiency so
sustainability managers are needed to
analyze and implement organizational
changes designed to reduce resource use
while building production now I've been
making this point in things I've been
writing and things I've been talking
about quite a while now wish to say that
you know in the in the 1930s and 40s and
50s and 60s we added financial
management and then information
management to what a manager had to
learn and understand to be affected to
be a sophisticated manager of a modern
organization you better know how to read
a financial statement you better
understand how to read a performance
measurement system and design one and
how to integrate that into your
financial measures well now we're going
to add the physical dimensions of
sustainability in resource use
environmental impacts that's going to
become the language of management and
you are going to be among the first
people using that because it's going to
give you a competitive advantage because
the companies that take that into
account are going to win Walmart didn't
come to this because they were
altruistic and love bunnies they came to
it because the green they liked was in
their currency okay and that is why this
is going to happen all of this is going
to happen because it's going to make
organizations more competitive in the
global marketplace because if it doesn't
it's not going to get used the
organizational capacity for managing
sustainability requires an understanding
of new technology and environmental
impacts public policy rules and
incentives financial costs and benefits
and the dynamics of organizational
change you need to know all of that to
make this happen and that's basically
what we've been trying to do this
Master in this course that's really been
what this whole thing has been about you
know and I want to talk a little bit
about government because first we have
this issue of global policy and as I
said I don't see the force of national
sovereignty fading I don't see a world
government coming in so nation states
are going to still be the main unit of
government but local governments are
going to do a lot here provincial and
state governments are going to do a lot
here and we're going to have to find
ways of coming to global agreements on a
lot of things because you know take an
issue like marine debris you know the
the bottles of beer that go into the
ocean in Germany you know are in Europe
i should say they find their way to our
shores you know if you you can look at
some of these slicks of garbage moving
across the ocean the i have a beach
house out in Long Island or house near
the beaches and it's called a beach
house of a block and a half from the
ocean but every day in the summer in
Long Beach they come there and they rake
the beaches with big tractors that rake
up the beaches and then guys follow it
with with with little sticks and with
garbage bags and they pick up all the
garbage because every and it's not
coming from the beach it's coming from
the ocean okay all that stuff is washing
unsure over and over again it's just a
metaphor because this stuff isn't that
harmful it's just it's just irritating
and unpleasant but some of the stuff
getting in there is not just irritated
unpleasant it's killing fish and it's
destroying natural habitats so we do
need to deal with that we need to figure
out ways of addressing these global
problems government is a central player
in establishing and maintaining the
sustainability at the community
city-state national international level
this idea is really to regulate economic
activity and I've often used the
metaphor of traffic regulation you know
in a city like New York you better have
a traffic light at most corners are the
cars you're going to crash into each
other in the modern comp
interconnected global economy we need
the same thing to make sure that we
don't crash into each other as we get
around from place to place the idea that
an unregulated market can achieve
sustainability is just absurd the market
can do a lot to make production more
effective and efficient that can make
our lives better but it is not going to
achieve sustainability without rules the
rules have to come from government so
government in the private sector have to
work together to advanced economic
development with the least impact and
this is really we have to get to a level
of sophistication that we certainly
don't see in Washington today we're
still fighting this ideological war of
the mid 20th and early 20th century now
the communists against the capitalists
this is a ridiculous ideological battle
it has nothing to do with reality the
most effective economies are going to be
the ones where the people that make
things and make services and the people
to do regulation learn to work together
in a sophisticated way and we have to
figure out how to do that if we don't
were doomed because we need a mixed
economy we need rules but we also need
the freedom for entrepreneurs to thrive
and this is not an easy thing to do but
we're going to have to figure out a way
to do it so that's basically the
conclusion of the class we need that
sophistication you've got to figure out
a way to make it happen and it's going
to happen I think but I think it's going
to happen because I'm one of these guys
that tends to be optimistic all right so
I think it's going to happen also
because we really don't have a lot of
choice